President Trump went on a mission last
night to show Pennsylvania voters how
much he needs them
polls show his support is declining in
the Rust Belt states that made the
difference for him back in 2016 and are
we Jiang is at the White House with more
we gia good morning good morning Tony
President Trump actually held a rally to
shore up support for a Republican
congressional candidate in a special
election today but it quickly became
about his own reelection his campaign
says they are focused on battleground
states not concerned but the president
is clearly aware of his competition
I'll be your ally gotta win this state
in montoursville Pennsylvania last night
President Trump tried to galvanize his
supporters in a battleground state
crucial to his re-election campaign
ticking off a list of accomplishments
when you have the best economy probably
that we've ever had I don't know how to
help you lose this election right
former and current Trump campaign
officials tell CBS News the economy and
new jobs are the stars of the 2020
PlayBook in Rust Belt states Michigan
Wisconsin and Pennsylvania which mr.
Trump won by less than one percent in
2016 and while the president's campaign
claims it sees the entire Democratic
field as one block they are clearly
developing an argument against former
Vice President Joe Biden Biden deserted
you he's not from Pennsylvania I guess
he was born here but he left you folks
he left you for another state over the
weekend Biden kicked off his campaign in
Philadelphia the single most important
thing we have to accomplish is defeat
Donald Trump a recent Quinnipiac
University poll shows in Pennsylvania
the president is trailing several
Democrats including Biden and Bernie
Sanders earlier Monday mr. Trump said
the numbers don't faze him I think we're
doing very well in Pennsylvania we won
it last time one former campaign
official tells me Biden is the only
Democrat who could steal votes away from
the president in the Rust Belt but he's
also confident Biden will fizzle out but
Gail others are not so sure and point to
Biden's ability to sway places in the
heartland among the president's base
supporters Thank You Asia and Biden's
numbers keep climbing thank you very
much